vous vous souvenez certainement de cette
polémique née place du tertre à paris
entre les peintres les restaurateurs et
les cafetiers cela propose des
emplacements la mairie de paris avait
annoncé qu'elle allait mettre de l'ordre
dans tout cela
depuis quelques jours chacun a donc son
mètre carré le reportage de bernard
s'égare
l'arrêté municipal de 117 n'étaient plus
appliquées du coup le droit du plus fort
tenait lieu de réglementation par
ailleurs place du tertre 60% des
artistes sont d'origine yougoslave 20 %
russe polonais ou japonais le reste
étant des natifs de la butte pour
chasser les faux artistes et notamment
les marchands de sérigraphie made in
hong kong
la mairie de paris a créé une commission
tripartite composée d'élus de
représentants du préfet de police et des
cinq représentants d'associations
d'artistes elle commerçants en fait il
s'agit de réserver les 150 emplacements
disponibles aux productions d'origine
montmartroise série ak seul critère pour
démêler les vrais d'artistes des fossés
de vérifier que ce sont bien les
artistes qui produisent et qui créent
des oeuvres ici qu'il s'agisse de 4
qu'il s'agisse d'ailleurs de
dessinateurs et portraitiste
nous avons mis au point une
réglementation si vous voulez et une
commission d'attribution de cartes
puisque le créeront des véritables
carrés avec des emplacements a dit
visuellement attribués et nous
choisirons des artistes qui créent sur
place et qui vivent sur place et non pas
du tout des vendeurs de soupe
ils ont pour dessein ce vocabulaire un
peu dur
on pensait de la nouvelle réglementation
ça va nettoyer un petit peu plus garder
quelques artistes voilà
sûrement sa mort ça va changer beaucoup
moins un peu trop de gens qui arrivent
et puis qu'ils savent pas vraiment qui
sont en vraiment être et puis qui se
fera aider ou alors sérigraphie
en tout cas désormais l'usagé du
chevalier est obligatoire les
reproductions sont interdites ainsi que
le racolage
mais il ne faudrait pas que cette
réglementation aboutissent à cause de la
peur du fisc à faire fuir les picasso en
herbe